jean marie bigard est ce que vous savez
coudre je couds très bien ouais je
recouvre à l'engager en public un peu à
la machine puisque un peu à la machine
et vous préférez la mer ou la montagne
la mer c'est un permis sans intérêt
comme ça on n'a pas dans merde avec la
presse quand vous étiez petit vous
aimiez l'école un oui oui je mets jamais
l'école louisa bien oui bonne réponse
est non je mets bien l'école et j'ai
l'impression qu'il me trouve disons
jean-marie tepa dumas perceuse au nom ne
va pas sa préférée les chats ou les
chiens
j'ai les deux oui et vous y croyez à ce
truc un peu mais j'aime bien je préfère
y croire que de ne pas y croire hec -
moi supplie droite tu mange beaucoup de
frites
répond pas à 5 on dit de moi que tu as
pensé à ce que toi tu penses à faire
rentrer du fioul
ah oui c'est pourtant avec tapas fermer
le gaz mais il le faut ça c'est bien ça
c'est la phrase branché en ce moment
j'étais en boîte de nuit et il faut que
je rende pas ce qui me livre le fioul à
8 heures ça fait super branché dis moi
ça va toi en ce moment il est nul ton
interview
c'est amusant intérêts oui comme ça n'a
pas dans merde qu'est ce qu'ils pensent
de la connaissance